um probably just growing up in front of
the spotlight
is extremely difficult and you're
growing and you're making mistakes
and everyone's judging you kylie jenner
is speaking out after the backlash over
her five thousand dollar donation to
former makeup artist
samuel rauda people say things all the
time
um and some things i just think feel
like responding to
so i just felt like responding to that
one jenner recently took to her
instagram stories
requesting that fans donate to samuel's
gofundme campaign
after he sustained an injury from a car
accident and is now in need for brain
surgery
the keeping up with the kardashians star
donated 5 thousand dollars to the
campaign
and encouraged her followers to
contribute people all over social media
have been slamming the self-made
billionaire
claiming she should have donated more
given her net worth
kylie took to her instagram stories to
clarify her donation and
intentions she said in part quote i feel
it is important for me to clear up this
false narrative that i've asked my fans
for money
and of not paying for my makeup artist's
medical bills
sam isn't my makeup artist and
unfortunately we don't have a personal
relationship
anymore but i have worked with him a few
years ago and think he's the sweetest
she went on to say after learning in
more detail about the accident
it compelled me to visit his gofundme
which was set at ten thousand dollars
they had already raised six thousand
dollars so i put in five thousand to
reach their original goal
and thought i'd post on my stories to
gain more awareness if anyone else
felt compelled to share or donate i
don't know how all of this got so
twisted but his family has reached out
through ariel
and are very appreciative of all the
donations prayers and love towards sam
kylie shared a second post to her
stories emphasizing that she takes
actions
from the heart and hopes she can
encourage others to continue to help